today we are going to be having a look
at the dot product and uh this is one of
those results which actually I don't
know if you realize this but uh vectors
at least the kind that you have been uh
learning over the last few weeks and
months they weren't in the uh in any HSC
course
um back when I was at school because
that's how old I am I learned everything
that I learned about vectors when I was
at University in fact and I remember
learning about the dot product and it
was one of those many examples uh where
I found out a formula for it and I could
compute that formula the formula is not
that complicated but I never really got
a sense for uh number one what that
formula meant and number two
um why that formula mattered like why
what um what result or why did I care
about this right so I'm going to try and
do a bit of both of those things today
which is why we're not going to go super
far into this concept because in fact
there's lots of things you can do with
the dot product and if I tried to ran
them all into one lesson uh we just
wouldn't do them justice so that's why
we're just gonna get a beginning into
the 3D Dot product and build on some of
the things you know from 2D which is why
um you've got here um I don't know if
you remember uh doing this in the first
the very first lesson that we had on 3D
vectors we created this table right and
we noticed how uh when we move into a
three-dimensional General system we take
a lot of the notation and the ideas from
two dimensions and we just say go again
we did it twice before now do it a third
time right so I wonder if and I am going
to slightly put you on the spot here but
if you can't um if it's it's sort of
foggy in your memory happy to help you
here
um I wonder if you remember for 2D
vectors what our definition for or
rather our formula for the dot product
was there were two of them I wonder do
you remember either of them
okay very good so let's just pause on
this for a second because this is and
it's worth by the way it's worth uh
rewriting this we'll all you'll see why
in a moment uh this is I guess you might
say the I would describe it as the polar
formula the polar formula and that's
because the whole idea of uh polar
coordinates is that we can say all right
if you've got magnitude and you've got
Direction so it's a vector way of
thinking right so you've got the um uh
the magnitudes here here and here and
then you've got the direction over here
right so what this is telling us is tell
us how long a is how long B is and then
what's the angle between the two of them
right and this just gives you the the
dot product okay
um fantastic we will come back to this
formula in a brief moment but do you
remember what the other one was it had
to do with the components so I often
call it component formula yeah what do
you remember
see
it again
X1 X2 okay all right so X1 X2 so the X
components of the first vector and then
the Y components of the the SEC of of
both of both vectors um you could call
the maximum X2 it's totally fine I'm
actually going to call them because you
can see um on the left hand side my
vectors are called A and B so um even
though it's just a notation thing right
I'm going to call this
um x a x b instead of x minus two but
it's not it doesn't really make a
difference right
um and then you've got uh the Y
components as well okay now if you just
have a look up right
um again this is what we looked at
extending two Dimensions into three
um I want you to just have a wild guess
right when we go into three dimensions
what would you imagine say for example
the component formula is probably easier
right it's
um you've got the X components monitron
and the Y components what would you
imagine happens when we extend this idea
into three dimensions what would you
include in addition to the X and the Y's
yeah very good so um this is a fantastic
guess right I think it's going to be
well I'll just continue the pattern
right we multiply the X components we
multiply the Y components and added them
why not add on the product of the Z
components okay now it turns out this is
exactly right um just like we're
following the pattern that's nice but I
actually want us to show why it is right
and to understand that we actually need
to look at this polar formula I think
it's it's a better
um definition of the dot product because
really what you're trying to understand
is how much are A and B Like A and B are
two vectors right somewhere anywhere in
three-dimensional space how much are
they working together with each other
and how much are they working against
each other right that's that's the real
question okay
so
um I want us to have a picture of this
right so what I'm going to do is let's
just draw kind of a couple of vectors
right something like this
and um of course they don't necessarily
actually have to be with their tails
together and their heads heading out
they really could be anywhere but
because we're understanding the
relationship between their magnitudes
and their directions right just placing
them together tail to tail just makes
them easier to interact with right
so if I call this a and this one B then
that Theta that angle in between them
is going to be in here right now if we
have a think about the the cosine
formula and this is going to be a bit
strange but um not the cosine formula
the the cosine graph I'm actually going
to dig a little bit into the
trigonometry so you understand what's
going on here and what this formula is
telling you and hopefully how I can
convince you that this definition makes
sense of how much are they working
together and how much are they working
against each other okay
can you do me a little favor um near
where you've you've drawn or written
this draw me up a small uh set of axes
as if we're drawing a cosine graph
because in fact that is what we're about
to do so not with a highlighter so let's
go ahead
there we go it only needs to be a bit
rough
so what we're going to do is we're going
to draw the regular cosine curve so it
looks something like this
okay and I want you to notice right the
normal cosine graph it goes from naught
to 2 pi I'm thinking in radians um how
by the way how comfortable are you with
radians at the moment is it still weird
do you still like default back to
degrees or are you pretty comfortable
um I'm comfortable with them but I do
get back to degrees Yeah yeah that's
that's totally fine it's um you know
we've been having you in degrees mode as
it were like as if if your brain was a
calculator we've had you in degrees mode
for um you know 95 of your life and then
we're like hey here's another way of
doing it and I have the Good Fortune of
because I've been teaching this for a
long time I've almost like it feels
equal to me but you will gain that
familiarity with time so what I've got
here is this normal graph does end at
two Pi radians 360 degrees however
because what we're measuring here is
um a an angle between two vectors right
you can see that if I um you know if I
had a vector like let's let's draw
another one over here right you don't
need to draw this part because your
diagram is going to get really busy
really fast right can you see if my B
actually headed off in this direction
you'd get a Theta of uh Pi radians do
you agree with that like they're they're
directly opposed to each other
and if I were to try and get like a
larger angle like a a reflex angle I
guess right if we were to I might even
take this and rotate it around right if
I took this and I said okay let's let's
spin it around this way right so now
I've tried to increase that angle Theta
what you've got is the fact that because
I'm just working out what's the angle
between them I've now got a smaller
angle this obtuse Theta on the other
side right so it doesn't really like
there's no reason why we would use
larger angles like bigger than Pi if I
can say the angle between the two
vectors as less than PI right so when we
think about this Theta that goes in the
dot product formula we're really
actually only thinking about not naught
to 2 pi but just naught of high are you
content with that so what I'm going to
do is I'll zoom into this a little bit
and I'm just going to emphasize
this section here and I'm just going to
end
at Pi okay
now you guys know we start at zero that
Pi on two is the uh intercept right
there and then in fact I don't really
need to worry about the rest of it so in
fact I'm going to sort of get rid of all
this stuff over here just so you don't
have to be confused by it here we go
so these are the values taken on by cos
Theta in between Norton Pi this is our
domain yeah
now I want you to think about this what
is this telling us okay well if I've got
two vectors and the angle between them
is zero right if the Theta is zero then
when theta equals zero what value does
cos Theta take on you can see it on the
graph right COS of zero is
one very good so this is the maximum
this is the highest that cosgro the
cosine graph goes right so this is kind
of like all right your your angle
between the two vectors is zero in other
words you're heading in exactly the same
direction yeah so this is
um you know you two both like trying to
get behind a car and push it in exactly
the same direction so your two vectors
are moving um together and that's why
you get that maximum value of of one
right but then if we sort of move along
the cosine graph right you can see as I
move over to Pi on two
um or as I get towards Pi on two your
angle is no longer zero the angle
between your two vectors is kind of
increasing so you're no longer pushing
in as much of the same direction does
that make sense the vectors are not
working together as much
if you get to a point where the angle
Theta between the two vectors is pi on
two so we would say that this is um in
two Dimensions we would call this
perpendicular but in three dimensions we
would say what
starts with an o yeah orthogonal right
so these two vectors are now orthogonal
so how much are they working together
with each other and the answer is
they're not working at all like if if
one of you was pushing behind the car
and the other person was pushing on the
side of the car and it's going to the
left or the right it's like hey you're
not helping me
um you're not really stopping me either
but we're not actually cooperating in
any sense and that's why COS of Pi on 2
is zero so you get a DOT product of zero
so the vectors are not working together
yeah
and then lastly we progress to this idea
of pass Pi on two so this is actually
this situation I've drawn in blue down
here right so now you've got an angle
that's obtuse between them so that's
what that's what this angle in here is
it's obtuse
so now you can picture here A and B
this is now like one of you who's behind
the car and the other person's like on
the front of the car and you're actually
pushing against each other so what can
you see about the cosine graph after you
go past pion2 when you've got an obtuse
angle between plan two and Pi what
values of cosine do you get
yeah very good so they're negative
because they're beneath the axis right
so this is our way of articulating that
the vectors are working against each
other so this is actually quite
important to say so if I said Theta is
greater than zero right
um what you've got is a is a picture
kind of like like this sorry not Theta
um cos Theta
when cos Theta is greater than zero
you've got these vectors sort of working
roughly in the same direction
so you're working sort of together
if you've got cos Theta equal to zero
right you either have them at right
angles to each other so they're
orthogonal
or one of them might be the zero Vector
in which case it's like one of you is
just standing on the side and not
pushing the car right so you're not
working together in fact it's just
independent they're nothing really to do
with each other the two vectors aren't
really contributing to each other and
they're not fighting against each other
and then lastly there's cos Theta being
negative so this is where you've got a
situation like this
right like that there's an obtuse angle
or even a straight angle right so these
are now working against each other
um and not only do we know how much they
are in relation to their angle but
obviously if one of the
um vectors was very large that in like
the the actual size of it so you can see
um our magnitude of a was really big
that would increase the the value of the
dog product so that just means they're
working more and more against each other
all with each other okay
all right so can I just pause there does
that make sense are you guys okay with
that understanding
um it is just so important that you get
an idea in your head for what these
things are doing
um just to give you like another side
example you'd have to write this down
but you can if you like
um you guys know the quadratic formula
right can you actually recite it to me x
equals what's on the top
very good so
um you've got these this big mess on the
numerator and then I've paused from
writing 2A because I'm going to do
something slightly different right
instead of writing 2A as just one
denominator down the bottom for a reason
that I'm going to hopefully make clear
in a second I'm actually going to
separate this into two fractions and I'm
going to divide both of them by 2A
now the reason why I'm doing this is
because I'm trying to with the dot
product right I'm trying to emphasize I
want you to know what the formula is
doing and why it's doing it don't just
see it as like oh there's some attitudes
and there's a cause in there for some
reason right in the same way I want you
to have a look at like the quadratic
formula and I want you to see do you
guys recognize what is this um result
out the front what is that for a
parabola
that's the it's it's where you'll find
the turning point right it's the axis of
symmetry it's the it's the middle of the
parabola right and then what you do is
then you say plus or minus so plus takes
you to the right and minus takes you to
the left
so you're moving on either side of it
and then what you get is is this thing
here on the end which tells you where
the roots are going to be right because
the roots are symmetrical around the
axis of symmetry that's that's why we
call it an axis of symmetry right so
when you look at the quadratic formula I
want you to see that it's like oh find
the middle and then go sideways the same
amount that's what the formula is
telling you and in the same way I want
you to look at the dot product formula
and I want you to say oh okay it's it's
work it's using colors because that'll
tell you whether they're working
together or against each other and then
it's got those Magnus there to work out
how much they're working together or how
much they're working against each other
okay